um everyone i'm sorry should i have your
attention please
thank you hi sorry i just have an
announcement to make
um okay
i have learned a lot about indian
culture tonight
but i have learned even more about
love and i know you're all thinking
who is this crazy gringo and what is he
talking about
well i'm not crazy maybe i'm crazy in
love
so without further ado
carol carol stills
i would like you to do me the honor
of making me your husband
oh michael what are you saying
can we talk about this in private i
didn't hear you
can we talk about this in private
oh okay that's nice
everybody enjoying their meal
hey babe yeah how about we take the beer
sign down until our guests leave and
then we can discuss it
no no i'm gonna leave it up i think it
ties the whole room together okay
[Music]
jan thinks hunter is very talented
you know what i don't think he's that
good
at least he's an artist bfd i'm a
screenwriter
and i'm a candle maker but you don't
hear me bragging about it no
all you do is you get me to try to work
on my rich friends
for an investment opportunity now i
would love to burn your candles
you burn it you buy it oh good i'll be
your first customer
you're hardly my first
[Music]
that is a two hundred dollar plasma
screen tv you just killed
good luck paying me back on your zero
dollars a year salary plus benefits babe
i have an announcement uh to make
i am moving to costa rica
thought about it for a long time now
and i'm finally gonna do it
so i'm just gonna hop the fence and jog
home now
so like
so i like
are you doing what are you doing i'm
rejecting your
kiss i didn't
could i have a ride home
if you sit in the back and do you
phyllis take bob vance
vance refrigeration to be your lawfully
wedded husband
i do ladies and gentlemen may i present
to you
for the first time as a couple mr and
mrs bob
vance
and do you bob take phyllis to be your
lawfully wedded wife
this next award goes somebody really
lights up the office somebody who i
think a lot of us
cannot keep from checking out
the hottest in the office award goes to
ryan the 10th yeah
[Applause]
you sexy things are being you here you
go
[Music]
hanging in a hundred and
there you go there you go what am i
gonna do with the award
nothing i i don't know what i'm gonna do
that's the least of my concerns right
now i'm going to give you a little
blast from the past of michael gary
scott when he was a child star
and a show that you might remember
called fundal bundle
okay without further ado ryan
let's have some fun that is miss trudy
can't tell from her costume but she had
an amazing body
okay you can fast forward and
i want you is that a real stop stop stop
stop
fire trucks yes that is uh edward
r meow
yes recess hey what's your name
my name's chet well hi chet is that chet
montgomery
uh i don't i don't know that is his
favorite color
meteorologist checking in with chet
doppler's up
i want to be on tv and he is on tv now
everybody please shut up please so you
don't miss it
okay next show what's your name that's
me
oh hi michael i'm ed well what's your
favorite subject
in school recess recess
so tell me what do you want to be when
you grow up
i want to be married and have a hundred
kids so i can have a hundred friends
and no one can say no to being my friend
uh oh okay well uh nice talking with you
michael
back to you miss trudy mr scott i know
you're a busy man
and your schedule moves around a lot but
for all your generosity through the
years
your tots who are ready to graduate
thought it was time to give you a proper
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
do to make a mr come true hey mr scott
what you gonna do what you gonna do to
make your dreams come true
you came into a loss made a promise that
made us honest made us realize
we don't need to cause you compromise
it possible for us to achieve the
improbable
hey hey hey
hey mr scott what you gonna do what you
gonna do to make your dreams come true
let's put your hands together and give a
warm welcome for the man of the hour
mr michael scott
all right um
i am never going to forget today not a
chance
i don't think i could ever give back to
you what you have given me today
who here's done something stupid in
their lives like skipped out on study
hall or
mix up the difference between a gym and
b jim that sort of thing show of hands
anybody
yes bunch of you okay well me too i've
done something stupid
which i would like to share um
should we go no no we're okay it's a
it's a double period
ah all right i came here today because i
promised you tuition
and tuition is very valuable but you
know what's invaluable
is intuition you know what that is that
is the ability
to know when something is about to
happen
does anybody out there have intuition
know what's gonna happen
next nobody okay you're gonna make me
say it
all right i am so proud
of all of you derek
and leferve and and ben and ayanna and
michaela
and nikki and jason and i'm
sorry okay so are spacing your name i'm
zion that was michaela's younger brother
well zion i am not going to be paying
for your tuition
which brings me to my main point and
that is that i will not be able to pay
for anybody's tuition
i'm so so sorry
what you're kidding me
you